واحد من اهم اخبار اليوم جيم من ليبيا
فوثيقه سريه للوكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه كشفت فقدان 2.5 من اليورانيوم
الطبيعي من احد المواقع في ليبيا من
البيان السري كان للمدير العام للوكاله
ووصلت نسخه منه للاعلام وفي بيقول انه في
زياره تفتيشيه لموقع من اللي كانت مخزنه
في كميات من اليورانيوم الطبيعي وادي
زياره اجل السنه عشان الاوضاع الامنيه في
ليبيا الان لمن قامت فيها الوكاله
المفتشين انه في عشره اسطوانات بتحتوي على
2.5 طن من اليورانيوم مو موجوده في الموقع
وتابع البيان ان الوكاله راح تكمل
اجراءاتها علشان تعرف ملابسات ازاله
اليورانيوم من المكان اللي تم التحفظ على
اسمه وما قيل عنه الا انه مو تحت سيطره
الحكومه هذا الاعلان قلبت الدنيا من اولا
سياسيا عن اللي سرقوا كيف انسرقوا من
المصلحه وهذا النوع من الاسئله لكن كمان
على الجانب الاخر قلب الدنيا مخاوف بتتعلق
بالسلامه وانتشار الاسلحه خاصه من قبل
خبراء الانتشار النووي فهؤلاء وكاله
الطاقه الذريه بيحدروا ان الجهل باستخدام
هذه المواد يمكن يشكل خطر اشعاعي هذا غير
انه قالوا كمان انه كل طن يورانيوم طبيعي
ممكن يتحول لخمسه فاصله سته كيلو جرام
مواد مستخدمه في الاسلحه وهذا بيجعل
العثور على المعدن ام المفقود امر عاجل
وخطير حقيقي هنا يعني في اسئله كثيره
صراحه اولا كل طن يورانيوم بيعمل خمسه
كيلو مواد مستخدمه في سلاح فقط هذه يعتبر
كثير وخطير يعني تانين قديش خطر انه ينسرق
هذا اليورانيوم واصلا اليورانيوم بكون باي
حاله مخزن واي احد ممكن يصنع منه سلاح
يعني الان يعني الموضوع يحتاج معرفه او
مثلا يعني منشات ضخمه يعني على العموم من
الاسكندريه دكتور علي عبد النبي نائب رئيس
المحطات النوويه سابقا وخبير الطاقه اهلا
فيك معانا دكتور علي اول شيء الكميه اللي
بنتكلم عنها وبتقول وكاله
الطاقه انه لازم يتم استرجاعها على الفور
هي فعلا كميه يعني خطيره لهذه الدرجه
طبعا
بشكركم على استضافتي في البرنامج
الموضوع امبارح
يعني الوكاله الدوليه بتاخد ذريه اتكلمت
صدر منها تقرير عن هذا الموضوع
والكميه طبعا لا يستهان بها اتنين ونص طن
عشر اسطوانات
هو من خمس يورانيوم ممكن يكون خام طبيعي
او ممكن يكون خام منفقه اللي هو العجينه
الصفرا او الكيكه الصفراء
هم قالوا ان هي الكعكه الصفراء
او الكعكه الصفراء يعني ايا كان
[موسيقى]
الكميه دي كميه كبيره اولا ما فيش جهه
حكوميه ليبيه
[موسيقى]
قالت ان هي المسؤوله عن هذا الموضوع
طبعا الموضوع انا شايفه ان هو
تحت مسمى سرقه
مواد نوويه طبعا الخوف ان هو يصل الى
ايادي الجامعات الارهابيه لان ممكن
يستخدموه النهارده القناه النوويه القذره
بتستخدم
العجينه الصفرا او يعني
او بتستخدمه
طبعا الاشعه اللي بتطلع من دكتور لما تقول
كيكه ايش يعني
يعني هي هو نفس الخامه اللي جايه من من
باطن الارض لكن
لها نوع من نوع من التنظيف بحيث ان هي
كانت يعني تبقى يورانيوم خام صافي ما
يبقاش في معه شوائب اخرى طيب الان الجهه
اللي سرقتها يعني
تقدر بكل سهوله مثلا انه تعمل منها سلاح
يعني
اه ممكن تعمل منها قنبله قذره قنبله نوويه
القذره القنبله النوويه القذره ده بتاخد
البودر ده او البودره دي اللي هي البودره
وبتحاول تنشرها في الجو بحيث ان
يعني الناس تستنشق هذا التراب او هذا
العفره بيدخل في صدرها او بينزل في التربه
النبات يمتصه الحيوان بيبقى في المواد
المشعه دي طبعا على المدى الطويل بيحصل ت
جمع يعني التجمع يعني جراحات متراكمه ممكن
يسبب سرطان
سرطان الرئه وده فيها خطوره كبيره يعني
طبعا
ايه الشائع هذا الموضوع انه فجاه كده
ينقال انه فيه رانيا مختفى
والله هو ده
الخبراء الوكاله الدوليه اللي اتخذوا هم
اللي اكتشفوا هذا الموضوع وممكن يكون فيها
حاجات تانيه وما اخفى كان اعظم الله اعلم
ايه اللي موجود تاني يعني لان طبعا ليبيا
غير مستقره يعني
جزء يعني طرفين بيتنازعوا على حكم ليبيا
ومشاكل بينهم وحروف بينهم فطبعا الاداره
في ازمه امنيه وفي جهات كثيره هتستفيد
ممكن من سرقه هذه المواد وحتى بيعها سواء
في السوق السوداء او بيعها الدول او او او
الارهابيه ده
تنشر الفساد في المجتمع اللي هو منحل زي
المجتمع الليبي سياسيه المنحل يعني مفيش
دوله ليبيا فين دوله ليبيا دلوقت ما فيش
ممكن تستغلها
ايوه طبعا طب لقاني كيف لما بيجوا
بيسرقوها بس يعني هي الواحد لما بيشوف
البيانات هذه يعني بيحس انهم كانهم يعني
جايبين انه كذا سياره ومحملينا اليورانيوم
وطالعين فيهم هم كده بيعملوها فعلا
يعني حجمهم صغير مش كبير لان اليورانيوم
كشفته عاليه تسعه 11 مره من كثافه الميه
اوكي
فهو قيمته الماديه هذا مثلا هذه اللي
بنتحدث عنهم الاثنين طن قديش ممكن تكون
الاوقيه دولار
اوكي يعني
بس انت بتتكلم مع واحده صفر اوقيه صفر
رياضيات صفر كذا فيعني يعني اعطيني كذا
بشكل عامل 2 طن بكم
انا لكن يعني يعني
هو غني مش رخيص لان
التعدين في
بياخد
تكاليف عاليه فهو هو غالي يعني انا ممكن
يعني
الكيلو ب 100 دولار مثلا يعني
ممكن اكثر 100 دولار ممكن اكثر من 100
دولار اوكي طيب احنا احنا بنشكرك على هذه
المداخله كان معنا من الاسكندريه دكتور
علي عبد النبي نائب رئيس المحطات النوويه
سابقا وخبير الطاقه شكرا لك
[موسيقى]